small things keep Ian going
a stove for a cup of tea fairy lights
for his cardboard home and a bit of
humor on the walls but life under the A4
in West London is hard Ian's mental
health is as precarious as his makeshift
Shack in November he was back out on the
streets after being released from a
psychiatric ward and after 12 years
clean he's back on crack and heroin so I
started dabbling probably four or five
weeks ago but relapsed properly as in
when I realized I had my habit back
about two weeks ago what what caused
that what just been messed up in general
by the surfaces you know but they proper
they're proper at me that they was meant
to have me rehoused and they didn't you
know I meant to have meetings with my
care coordinator once a week I've not
had one meeting I've spoken to where not
even five times I don't think
Ian embodies a prevalent issue among the
homeless community
in the general population 12 percent of
people have a mental health problem but
a recent report by homeless link found
the number of homeless people diagnosed
with a mental health problem has soared
from 45 percent of people between the
years of 2012 to 2014 to 82 percent of
those homeless between 2018 and 2021 45
percent of those self-medicate with
drugs or alcohol increasing numbers are
unhappy with the level of mental support
20 said they received no support at all
it's hard to illustrate this decline
among such an invisible population but
one thing about Ian helps we've met him
before in 2020 during the pandemic he
was living in a hostel and even then was
feeling unsupported yeah you get
mentally unwell you get sectioned you
get put in hospital they tell you hey
when you get out you're gonna have a
community mental health Team you're
going to have a care coordinator we're
going to put these things in place you
get out you don't hear anything from
them literally it just stops
there's been times before where I've
been section and I've got out of
hospital and I've been okay for a day or
two and then I've just relapsed because
there hasn't been anything there to
catch you when you're coming out
it's about a little change please Ian's
decline in two and a half years is
visible the Vicious Cycle he described
continued at Rock Bottom he was
sectioned again and again any progress
was undone when after being discharged
he ended up back on the streets
what's your coldest nights like in that
house because it's get it has been
getting colder even before this
um yeah been pretty harsh I know someone
died on the Shepherds for screen the
other day as well
someone or someone passed away it's just
too cold or yeah sleeping on now
sleeping on the ground just died in
their sleep
so no don't you worry about that when
you go to sleep
death doesn't bother me
doesn't bother you it doesn't bother me
what if you died in your sleep it
wouldn't bother you
yeah
sadly no no I wouldn't why not
good question
Ian's case raises many questions Brent
Council who last housed him said we have
tried to help and support Mr Harrison
who feels unable to return to his home
in Brent he has turned down an offer of
emergency accommodation and we lost
contact before other offers could be
made our priority is to see Mr Harrison
safe and well we are Keen to meet Mr
Harrison as soon as possible to ensure
he gets all the help and support he
needs
under emergency winter measures Ian has
been found temporary accommodation he
says maybe next year he can break the
cycle
Jason Farrell Sky News